listen where we are with science and
technology is completely contingent
matter I mean there's nothing inevitable
about it the Industrial Revolution why
would it happen who would have predicted
it would happen in some grisly rainy
bits of North England called in the 18th
century well there was coal elsewhere
and could have happened anywhere it
happened there that's one of those frail
constructs that so the other thing just
to come back to my story about people
staying standing in line for an iPhone 4
is that I was quite interested in
technologies that we all take for
granted then become very grubby you know
so it is an absolute miracle to fly from
San Diego to San Francisco in an hour
and a half but it's just such a drag
luggage carousel the security oh yes you
can see the clouds in the Ventana
wilderness but you know that's just the
way in which an iPhone smartphone ends
up in your sock drawer mm-hmm or in the
hands of your grandchildren discarded so
in this world I wanted the grubby
reality mm-hmm with the Future poured
into it so you could have 400 mile an
hour trains on you know levitated by
magnetic force zipping you from San
Francisco to to LA mm-hmm whether it be
crowded and dirty and noisy and the
windows will be filthy and it will just
be another ball you know the necessary
things of life and you can't check in
your luggage you have to heave it up
under the rug luggage rack yourself and
it's it's it's that rub off of when the
shiny future arrives it rapidly absorbs
itself into our endlessly untidy bedroom
as it when our teenage bedroom of social
reality that's what fascinates me
when messy humans get their shiny new
toys the shine goes off very quickly